okay last one symmetry we're talking
about functions right what kind of
symmetry do functions have you know two
kinds you can add the beat one or even
right now think for a second we're
talking about inverse functions not
invest relations so one of those kinds
of symmetry is not very useful to me
which one is it even symmetries kind of
a bit of a pain for me right why is that
can you remember we looked at it lost
this amazing very good if you have an
even function don't draw this if you
have an even function such as the moment
that yesterday which is just the
parabola right it fails the horizontal
line test
in fact that's kind of a point of an
even function that it fails the
horizontal line test everywhere right
every value you choose get in trouble
okay so that's kind of a problem so I'm
not gonna talk about even functions at
all I'm just gonna talk about on one
symmetry in brackets you can put in odd
functions because that's where it
matters okay now I'm gonna pause for a
second like remember when we started we
talked about this guy here increasing
decreasing functions right and then I
showed you I drew a picture and when
you've worked it out together before I
show you this picture I wonder if he can
reason out what property might kind of
flow from this if you started with an
odd function number one what might you
be able to conclude from the inverse
about the universe I should say and
number two how would you actually show
that's a case right apartment or even
shop is there a more rigorous way that
we could do it okay let's quickly
drawing on function give me an odd
function to draw
let's do it it's good that we picked
like music you because it is the
definition of an odd function okay WI
past these Michaels X cubes what's the
inverse I know what's the inverse gonna
look like tell me tell me something
about it it's gonna be yeah so this is
increasing it's not strictly increasing
its increasing so I'm also gonna get
another increasing function I notice
that there's a stationary point here
like this there would be a horizontal
tangent which means it for the inverse
there's going to be up radical changes
very good sits gonna go through like
that and when you turn it over you do
the reflection the cube root of x looks
like this okay you can see the symmetry
it's a very very nice isn't it okay so
now you see the Big Shot and you've got
life is X cubed and you've got y equals
x to the power okay what do you think
we're going to say as a property of the
inverse of an odd function they don't
need to intersect
yeah there's rotation now yes we have a
phrase in function land for when a
function has rotational symmetry about
margin week over there not function
right a why cause execute it you can you
can spin it around the origin and it is
the same once you go on pi radians all
the way around okay yes the King County
is all reversed isn't it yes that's
right okay now I'm gonna take all of
these things are true I'm just gonna
take the simplest one that we said that
the inverse of a non function is also a
known function okay so I'm going to
print them we're gonna do an
algebraically this time though because
it's really not that hard and I'll help
you understand the way these functions
Internet okay so let's start off if f of
X is odd what is the definition
algebraically
of a non-functioning okay you can set it
a couple ways depending where you want
to put your negative signs on the other
set this way massive negative x equals
the negative of X like that's that's
what we would say okay of course I can
put the minus sign over here so long as
I've got the right configuration okay
now if that is true I want to make some
statement about the inverse function
right what am i required to prove if
what I'm suggesting what I'm proposing
is that this being line makes this thing
wide how do I stay what's my end goal if
I want my last line to be an inverse of
negative x again if it's odd then it
should be negative right like it's
exactly the same as at all line because
that is the definition of odd function
okay so this is what I'm trying to get
this is where I'm trained in done hmm so
how am I gonna use that so do that have
a look at whatever the last couple of
days what do you have at your disposal
you actually don't have that many tools
in your toolbox yes
what could you possibly use I've made a
lot of arguments geometrically so far
right I've only made a very small number
algebraically that means you don't have
to have any quiz to go off even though
I'm late I'm gonna give you a minute to
have a look through this not that much
look through everything we've written
that investments in so far is there
anything that can help you get there
can you do that forever 30 60 seconds
different let me show you what I've got
in my head okay let me point out you
know almost nothing about these
functions right you don't know what f of
X is I'm giving you ID so this one's
that I mean I showed you a picture but
this one who knows what it is okay you
know almost nothing about it you did you
know one finger which is that F inverse
is indeed the inverse of the original
functions then by definition what can I
do
combine these two functions together to
give me something that I know if they
really are an original and an inverse
yeah very good thanks
this this is the definition of an
inverse function right this is the
algebraic one this is the geometric one
right the flipping thing okay now this I
know every inverse behaves like this if
it really is the inverse okay so I know
that that's good I'm gonna take that I'm
gonna keep that in the back of my mind
and I'm gonna run with it okay
now look at this per se have a look at
this guy over here huh rather than just
putting in f of X I'm going to put in
something that I noticed something about
namely this guy I know something about
this guy I could do this a variety of
ways by the way but I'm going to do this
I'm gonna do this now by the fact that f
is odd they form this I can replace with
this degree of that I think that the
same thing so this equals yes yep
okay so so this is just something I'm
keeping in the back of my mind and then
this is what I've written do everything
okay now hold on a second
what's careful what's this thing over
here on the left hand side according to
this you if you take the inverse of a
function of a number any number your
life you just get the number back won't
you but in this case I'm gonna get this
do you agree with that because the
number one happening to be placing at
the moment is negative X yes okay no
watch carefully right when you have a
look at this same thing right
think about this the other way around
this is like putting a minus sign here
if I multiply the right-hand side by
negative 1 what should I do the
left-hand side to make sure it's still
in equations and it's up multiply it by
negative 1 right to agree with that so
this I can say it is this degree with
that the right-hand side hasn't changed
oh that's that's just that okay but I've
used some arguments from here to here
and here to here you see that I've used
this sum this is y and I put in a box
I've used it twice
in different ways okay but now look look
at it stare really hard okay it's a bit
hard to see because it's kind of like us
too much notation in my way so to help
you get away from that I'm going to say
let's introduce a let's just introduce a
new variable to give this function
something a bit easier to work with
let's call that you okay if I do that I
can strike this nice and simple over
here I have that right what do I have on
the right hand side
that's the definition that's the
definition of an odd function right I
could just say I've got the one way
around but you know I can just replace
those with X's if I want because it's
just a variable the variable of any kind
right just like f of X was a variable
user variable X is another one okay that
kind of dummy behavior do you maybe saw
it before
so therefore F inverse is odd okay so
you can see here pictures are nice
pictures it good they help you
understand things but this is not a
proved anything here I've just got
something to look at which is nice this
is proof this is rock-solid you can
stand on this and you can make
conclusions